ALRIGHT SO THE ASSEMBLY OF OUR
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER WE
WILL BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
GOOD EVENING WE WILL HEAR BILLS
TO THIS COMMITTEE.
THE ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT.
TWO AND NINETY SIX PLEASE NOTE
OUR GUIDELINES FOR BILLS FOR
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY STILL OUT
TESTIMONY FROM TWO WITNESSES
[inaudible]
SUPPORT [inaudible] TWO
WITNESSES. FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
BUT YOUR ABILITY TO BE SO SAYING
IS MUCH APPRECIATED TODAY.
I WILL ALSO CALL FOR TWEENER
TESTIMONY FOR THOSE NEITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION MEASURES.
ONE WE KNOW A QUORUM AND SO WE
WILL NOW.
NO LONGER BE.
HOPE THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND TO
CALL.
AND THAT OF SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MEDINA PRESIDENT
BAKER ARAMBULA.
BLOOM CHáVEZ HERE.
IRWIN.
KILEY.
LEVINE VERY LOW HERE.
PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WEBER.
YEAH BUT QUORUM WE WILL BEGIN.
WITH SENATOR DE LEóN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO MR DAILY SECURITY.
WILL CALL [inaudible] FIVE THE
LITTLE.
FIVE THIRTY THIS BILL SIX COOPER
COLLEGE ACCESS TAX.
REFUND.
THE PROGRAM POVERTY WILL
ESTABLISH.
MY HOPE OUR SCHOOLS AS WELL AS
COLLEGE ACCESS TAX.
TAX CREDIT WOULDN'T TELL BACK
WHEN WE FOURTEEN LOVE MEASURE
THAT I WORK.
WITH SENATE BILL SUBCOMMITTEE.
THE PROGRAM WAS CREATED WITH THE
GOLD HELP LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
HIGHER EDUCATION.
TAX PAYER CURABLE DONATIONS ARE
DIRECTED TO THE CALIBER OF IT'S
TAX.
CREDIT BY INCREASING THE CREDIT
PERCENTAGE --
ORIGINALLY OF START AT 50%
INCREASE TO FROM THE CRACKERS.
OF THE ABOUT CONTRIBUTED BY THE
TAXPAYER INCREASING THE TOTAL
AGGREGATE IT CRIED ABOUT THOUGHT
IT'S COOLEY COLLEGES WHICH IS
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO ONE
BILLION.
AUTHORITY WAS TO MAKE THIS CRIED
EVEN MORE ATTRACTIVE THEREBY
ENCOURAGING MORE CALIFORNIA'S.
TWO WEEKS CLOUT WITH THIS CHAIR
MADAM VICE CHAIR --
WAS JUST --
JOIN US OUR DISTRICT WE ASK FOR
A NIGHT OF THANK YOU MANY WILL
TAKE IT.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OKAY RIGHT THERE REALLY STATE
HAS ON THAT THE NON TUITION --
DRIVING THAT PROCESS AND IS
HEARING CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
ACCESS WORK PROVIDES LIVING
EXPENSE --
COVERAGE FOR STUDENTS THAT ARE
VERY LOW INCOME STATE AND THE
COLLEGE ACCESS TASKER.
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TOUGH I'VE MADE THE UNITED.
HOW DOT AWARD KEPT PACE SINCE IT
WAS CREATED UP CLOSE FORTY FIFTY
YEARS AGO IT WILL BE WORTH OVER
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS TODAY?
THAT'S ATTRACT INFLATION
ACTUALLY TRACK [inaudible]
TENSIONS.
THE MAIN DRIVERS WHICH ARE THE
PIECES OF THE COUNTIES ARE GOING
FASTER THAN INFLATION HOUSING
HEALTHCARE THROUGH THAT SORT OF
THING BILLION PERSONS.
SO BECAUSE ACCESS CASH FOR TO
GIVE US MORE MONEY TO GET MEDIA
STUDENTS AT THE STATE AND
THEREFORE WE SUPPORTED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS DEFINITELY --
PRESIDENT IMPORTANT A ALONG WITH
[inaudible]
DIRECTOR [inaudible]
THEY LIKE I'M HERE [inaudible]
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BECAUSE THEY SAY SAY YOUR NAME
AND WHO YOU REPRESENT WITH ANY
OTHER WITNESSES AND THAT
SUPPORT.
ANY [inaudible]
WIENER.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD EVENING THAT MEMBERS I'D
JENNIFER BAKERY.
I APOLOGIZE [inaudible]
TO FORMER COLLEAGUE BOB AGAIN
COLLEGE.
SP FIVE THIRTY NINE CERTAINLY I
I DO WANT TO KNOW THAT WE
ABSOLUTE [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL THE CREATIVE COSTS HARRY
[inaudible]
INCREASING UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
OPPOSE THE DO YOU BELIEVE
[inaudible]
DEFINITELY.
IT CONTINUES TO CHECK AWAY IT
GENERAL FUND PROCEEDS TAX AND
CALCULATE.
CHIEF IT PROPOSES TO LET
TAXPAYERS REDUCE THEIR TAXES BY
SAID MAKING USUALLY BECAUSE
ACCESS CREDIT.
FOR BECAUSE UNDER THIS
LEGISLATION GENERAL FUND
PROCEEDS IT TAXES WILL BE REFUSE
IT WILL NECESSARILY HAVE THE
EFFECT OF LOWERING THE MEASURE
[inaudible]
WELL.
THE FACT THAT YOU GENERAL FUND
MAY BE REIMBURSED.
FOR REVENUE LOSS DOES NOT
UNFORTUNATE [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
SO.
KEEP YOU.
FOR YOU SO WHILE WE DO SUPPORT
GIVING STUDENTS [inaudible]
ECONOMIC [inaudible]
SELECT HEALTH [inaudible]
I AGREE.
HOLES HE DO NOT BELIEVE SHOULD
BE [inaudible]
REALLY [inaudible]
VIKING [inaudible]
FORTUNATELY.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
THAT'S GREAT SO [inaudible]
IF.
IF APPROVED AND HOW MANY
STUDENTS WOULD YOU EXPECT THAT
WOULD BE.
A FEW.
OF THEM [inaudible]
NUMBER OF TAXPAYERS WHO ACTUALLY
DRIVE DOWN THE STREET
[inaudible]
SO PERHAPS [inaudible]
VOTE.
SO DO WE HAVE PROCEEDS FROM THE
COLLEGE.
CRITICS MIND ARE DISTRIBUTED IS.
EVERY YEAR ANNUAL LEAVE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY IN THE EQUALLY
DISTRIBUTED AMONG CALTRAIN THE
RECIPIENTS SO IN RECENT YEARS --
WE'VE FIRST TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN DOLLARS --
NINETY THE HOPE IS THAT WITH A
MORE VALUABLE CREDIT THAT NUMBER
WILL PROCEEDS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WE HAD A MOTION BY.
DOCTOR RUMBULA AND SECOND BY
MISTER LOW --
THE THAT THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
IT ENJOYS A SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION.
I AGREE THAT WE NEED TO FIND
CREATIVE WAYS TO INCREASE
FUNDING TO THE GUT CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
BUT I AM CONCERNED WITH THE
POTENTIAL FOR UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT COULD.
HARM STUDENTS TO THE STATE DOES
NOT [inaudible]
POTENTIAL LOSSES. TO THE C. A.
T. C. PROGRAM.
NOT REACH ITS FULL POTENTIAL.
WE HAD A MOTION A SECOND --
MADAM SECRETARY.
LIST APPEARING SHOULD LIKE
DEFINITELY [inaudible]
CHAIRMAN VICE.
THE GARAGE WHICH UP --
TO TO PRESENT THIS MAN.
IF YOU BUILD UPON WHAT WE
BELIEVE IN A RAINY HE'LL BE
[inaudible]
WAY.
TAX CREDIT WHICH HAS LED.
BOB AND THE WHOLE FAMILY.
PROFIT WE CAN AGREE THAT.
TAX CREDIT POLICE OF THE
TELEGRAPH PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
--
DEALS WITH --
NOT PEOPLE TWELVE ABOUT.
FOURTEEN AS WELL AS WE RECEIVE
CALIFORNIA AND CAL SEACM.
STUDENTS OF ALL THOSE LOW
INCOME.
STUDENTS HELP GRANTEES ACOSTA
PRIVATE BECAUSE IT'S A VERY
SOLID.
THE STAFF SEE.
ON OUR OR ANOTHER.
FRONT NOT PROFIT.
COLLEGE.
THE FOLKS IDEA OF THE SEA.
UTILIZES CREATIVE INNOVATIVE
IDEA -- IN
OTHER STATES --
PRETTY GOOD RED STATES SAVINGS
ALLEN ALABAMA --
AT ARIZONA.
FLORIDA IS RATED IS SOLIS RIGHT
NOW.
OF THESE AFFRONT PURPOSES --
WHICH I THINK WE WOULD.
LITTLE CONSENSUS WE WOULD ALL
AGREE BIPARTISAN FASHION IS THIS
CAN.
TIME DOT USE OF THE TAXPAYER
FUNDED VOUCHERS FOR POLITICAL
OFFICE.
THIS CASE WE'RE USING IT IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
GIVEN THE THAT MUCH SHE FUNDING
TODAY HAS NOT TALK.
OF PROP --
NINETY EIGHT THE EDITOR
CONSEQUENCE --
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE
WOULD BE --
IT SPACE ON WHAT.
COULD BE BUT TO DATE THAT HAS
HAPPENED SINCE I STARTED THIS
IN.
TWENTY OF OF FOURTEEN SIMILAR
BILL THAT PASSED ON TO MAKE SURE
WE DO FROM.
FLOOR THE FAMILY [inaudible]
BOB BURKE.
WHICH HAS A YOU'RE ON NOT QUITE
SURE PERCENT BUT FOR MORE
OPTIONS IF YOU WILL MIGHT REDUCE
TAYLOR HOW GRANT.
PROGRAM FOR DOMES.
LAWS.
BOTHERS ME [inaudible]
NCLEX.
YEAH GRADUATE NOBLE.
SO WITH THAT I THINK IF YOU
WILL.
CARE ABOUT A VICE CHAIR
COLLEAGUES.
RESPECT LAUGHS WHEN I SO MADAM
SEARCH EVERY CALL THE ROLL.
EMOTIONS DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER AYE
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA AYE ARAMBULA
AYE BLOOM [inaudible]
CHAVEZ PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
I WEBER I THE THINGS HE DOES
ARE.
THE VOTERS NINE ZERO YOUR BILL
IS OUT CENTER.
THANK YOU.
AND WE'LL GO TO ITEM THREE SB
[inaudible]
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR SENATOR LEYVA.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR.
BEING REVERSED HOTEL HAD A
PERFECTLY ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY I THINK
YOU AND NOW OFFERS HIGH.
EVEN WITH THIS MATTER.
AS WE THINK SOME COURSE URGENTLY
NEEDED TO KEEP OUR FIREFIGHTERS
SAY AS A ALL THAT YOU
[inaudible]
WILD FIRES.
THE BILL SO GOOD FOR YOU.
OKAY BICU ONE TO BE A LITTLE
INFORMATION BUT I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT.
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE.
SIZE AND INTENSE. THREE DECADES
PASSES SIXTEEN THE WORST IN THE
YEARS AHEAD.
MAKING MATTERS WORSE WE ARE
LEARNING FROM OUR STAFF WRITERS
I'M ANY FIRES IN THE WILD.
URBAN INTERFACE FOR THE W. BY IS
WHEN THE UNDERSTOOD HOUSING THIS
OCCUPATION.
WE'RE SENATOR FIREFIGHTERS
ANGELES ONLY IN WHICH WE LACK
THE BEST AND MOST CURRENT
STRATEGIES.
PROTECT THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY
WE KNOW THEY PUT THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE EVERY TIME THEY GO OUT.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ALONE
MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
FIREFIGHTERS FROM CALIFORNIA.
RESPONDED THAT FIRES ACROSS THE
STREET STATE MAJOR PUSH FOR THE
PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL LIMITS
FOR TWO WEEKS AT A TIME WITHOUT
BREAKS.
IN EXTREME HEAT INCREASINGLY
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS WE SHOULD
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MINIMIZE
AND IF THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
RISKS ARE FIREFIGHTERS.
EXPERIMENTS IN THE WW I AREAS OF
STATE.
THE RESEARCH WILL BE LED BY ONE
OR MORE FREE IF YOU CAN.
DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO MINIMIZE
HELP SEEKING BRICKS EXPERIENCE
BY FIREFIGHTERS AND IMPROVE
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS IN COMBAT
FIRES.
JOINING ME TODAY IS MY JOINT
AUTHORED SENATOR REQUIRE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JERRY CAN OVER THERE AND READ
THE SUBSTANCE WE REPRESENT.
CAL FIRE VERY VERY BRIEF WE'VE
REPRESENTED FORTY YEARS IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS WE'VE HEARD
STORIES FROM PATRICK
FIREFIGHTERS.
THERE SEEN FIRES THEY'VE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE WE LOST A
FIREFIGHTER THIS YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY A TORNADO THAT WAS
CREATED BY THE FIRE AND FIRE.
WE HAVE FIREFIGHTERS WHO'D BEEN
ONLINE OF LAST YEAR DID NOT
SLEEP AT HOME ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DAYS.
WHERE FIREFIGHTERS DROP THERE
FOR FIFTY DAYS WITH ONE DAY OFF?
FIFTY DAYS WITH TWO DAYS OFF
WHICH MEANS THEY DON'T GET TO GO
HOME THEY HAVE TO SLEEP ON THE
GROUND.
WITH THIS LEGISLATION WILL DO
ALLOW US TO STUDY THE LONG TERM
IMPACTS THESE FIREFIGHTERS.
SOFT.
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'VE HAD WE
GREW OR FIGHTING.
COMPANIES.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FURTHER WITTICISMS
SUPPORT EVER MEMBERS.
PROUD TO REPRESENT.
FROM THE MIDDLE. TWENTY ONE FOR
EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME RIGHT
NEXT TO MY MEMBERS WHO REPRESENT
MANY IN YOUR COMMUNITY GO OUT
[inaudible]
DAVID.
AND ANY BETWEEN HERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WELL.
CLINTON I THINK MEANT THAT WE
HAD ALREADY.
QUESTION FROM MS BAKER YOU.
ARE THANK YOU FOR THE BALLOT YOU
KNOW.
YEAH.
BUT IF YOU CLEAR SUPPLY SENT
BOYCOTT TROOP IS THAT.
AND WITH THAT FIRE DEPARTMENT
PLEASANTON LIVERMORE.
AND WE DON'T SEE HIM IN SOME
WAY.
AND I THINK HIS FAMILY I THINK
OF OTHERS AND SO MANY THAT ARE
DOING MUTILATE ALL.
I AM CONCERNED WELL I I JUST
WONDER WHY THERE ISN'T ALSO
LOOKING AT THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ISSUE BOTH FORCE
MANAGEMENT VISITATION MEASURE
WHICH IS PART OF I WAS I THINK
IS WHAT IS SENATOR FIREFIGHTERS
OUT INTO THE WORLD TO FIGHT
THESE.
VERY DIFFERENT FIRES NOW IS
THERE.
INTENTIONAL COMPONENT OF WHY
THAT WAS LEFT OUT OF THE BILL I
THINK TRUTH INCLUDING SEPARATE
ISSUES.
STUFF LIKE THAT.
KIND OF COMMODITY YES THEY ARE
THEY ARE TWO SEPARATE ISSUES
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION THROUGH
FIFTY YEARS.
THERE ARE STUDIES BEING DONE
PRESENT.
THAT YOU NEVER SEE CAMPUSES THAT
FOCUS ON FORESTRY AND FOREST
MANAGEMENT MANAGEMENT COLLEGES
CLAIM.
CONSERVATION BIOLOGY.
IN THOSE.
FUNNY LOOKING AT IT IN
CALIFORNIA THEY ARE --
MADE BECAUSE I WOULD ENCOURAGE
US TO GIVE EQUAL TREATMENT TO
THAT.
THE WONDERFUL TONIGHT NDA
FIREFIGHTERS OUT INTO.
IF YOU AGENTS OR TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE KNOW MUCH MORE ABOUT HOW WE
CAN BETTER PREVENT CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE CONFRONTING.
AND NOT JUST.
NO FORCE IN.
THE PINES.
THERE SISTER LIKE MINE WHICH
OPENED LAST LANDS AND IN THE
COASTAL DISTRICTS THAT YOU KNOW
ARE ARE ALSO SALINE THIS.
I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
I I HOPE WE CAN ALL.
BE MINDFUL THAT.
THIS IS AN INCOMPLETE. FOR ALL
WE THANK YOU.
ANY THER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS MEDIA COMMENT BUT
IN ADDITION TO THE FIREFIGHTERS.
NOW HAVE BEEN OUT THERE.
THEMSELVES NORTH AND WALDRON
HIMSELF DEPENDING ON SIX WEEKS
THERE'S ALSO BEEN.
MADE THAT HAVE WORKED A LONG.
PLAYERS AND SO NOT SURE IF THAT
WOULD BE PART OF YOUR STUDY OR
WE AS A BODY LOOK MORE INTO THAT
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK A LOT OF
PUBLIC.
I UNDERSTAND HOW THAT
[inaudible]
AND ARE THE CHILDREN CAME.
WHAT IS THE AFTER EFFECTS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
AND SENATOR --
WHEN DID ASK IF I HAD YOUR
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS THE?
QUESTIONS ARE ADDRESSED BY THE
ANALYSIS ON PAGE.
FOUR YES IT HOUSES.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
LIKE THE CLOTHES AND PUBLISHED
THE VERY QUICKLY CARE ACT THIRTY
SECONDS IN.
SIMILARLY WHILE WEARING.
I REPRESENT AREAS WELL.
RECEIVE THE FIRST TIME DOZENS
AND DOZENS FIREFIGHTERS FOR ON
THE FRONT LINES HELD THEIR HOMES
ARE BEING DESTROYED BY FIRE.
BY A STAIN ON THE FRONT LINES WE
TO PROTECT THEIR NEIGHBORS.
SO NOT ONLY ARE WE SEEING
PROGRAM ALWAYS OPTION.
PROMOTION POLL THIS ALL POLL.
BUT THEY ARE NOW.
OF LIKE THOUSANDS OF OTHERS.
THAT HAVE MADE THEIR REFILL
THEIR ABOUT.
NURSING THIS DAY IN AND DAY OUT
ACROSS THE STATE AN INDIVIDUAL.
IS THERE HOMES DESTROYED.
SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR FOCUS AND YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I THINK IS BEYOND TIME
WILL SPECIALLY AS WE SEE THE
SIZE AND SCOPE WHILE THE FIRES
IN THE STATE.
BEING PUSHED YEAR AFTER YEAR.
THANK YOU DISTRICTS ALLIANCES
MANY WITHIN THE BOCANEGRA WHERE
I LIVE WE USE THAT WE YEAH SO
BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU SHOULD KNOW
YOU ARE AND WHAT REALLY HAPPENED
[inaudible]
SILENTLY ON AND SENATOR MCGUIRE
ENSURING.
DURING THE HOUSE FIRE ALL THE
FIRES LAST [inaudible]
YEAR.
AS WE'RE GOING THERE.
I'M.
SURE ON HOW THAT FOR THE PUBLIC
ARMENIA FIREFIGHTERS MARGIN OF
MY STREET --
IT IS ALSO LIKE THAT HAPPENS YOU
REALLY DON'T [inaudible]
HOW?
BRADFORD ATRISK WHEN IT HAPPENS
TO YOU -- I
CALLED MY WIFE AS I WAS LEAVING
I TOLD HER WHAT SURE IF YOU
[inaudible]
CALLING.
AND SHASTA LIGHTS UP WITH ME.
WILL YOU TAKE HIS ARE IN THERE.
HE OF COURSE THAT WILL PUT ON
THE WAY HOME MARK [inaudible]
YEAH.
ANYHOW IT'S GREAT THAT HE SAID.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL.
FOR TO WAS MOVED BY MISTER LOWE
AND SECOND BY DOCTOR ROOM BELOW
[inaudible]
A TRIBUTE SCUTTLED.
THE MOTION IS TO USE PASSED.
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE LIVING BY BLOOM AYE
CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE AYE AYE LEVINE
AYE LOW I KNOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA AYE
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I IT SEEMS THIRTEEN ZERO
TO LIVE OUT.
WE HAVE TO CARRY ME THROUGH
MEMBERS.
A LITTLE VOTER ITEM.
ONE MR LIVING DEATH.
WAY BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
HIGHLIGHTED.
A BILL TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
[inaudible]
ENROLL ONLINE [inaudible]
YES HE'S [inaudible]
YOU ARE.
AND THAT WAS.
NO.
REPORT.
NOT THE RIGHT KIND CARING LOYAL
SO [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WE ARE.
BUT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY TWEETERS ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MISTER LEVINE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
NOTHING.
WELL THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING A
BILL.
AND AS WE EXPAND FURTHER INTO
ONLINE EDUCATION IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
SEGMENTS TAKE THE TIME TO
NECESSARILY ANALYZE OF THE
PROGRAM.
ADDRESS SERVING STUDENTS SO WE
HAD A MOTION BY DOCTOR HUMBLER.
TAKEN BY DOCTOR WEBER AND
SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS.
RECOMMENDATION THAT SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN THAT
FIRST MEETING CURRENT
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER AYE
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA AYE ARAMBULA
AYE BLOOM.
I CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE I'D LEVINE AYE
LOW AYE.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA AYE
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THIRTEEN ZERO BUILDINGS
OUT.
AND WE ARE THE ONES WHO WILL DO
THE ADD ONS TO ABSENT MEMBERS.
S. B..
FIVE THREE NINE WOMEN WHO.
HIGH LITTLE I HIGHLY.
NOT MEDICARE.
KILEY NONE MOVING [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PATTERSON ON YEAH HI SANTIAGO
HIGH.
IT'S A BIG.
WELL HERE IT IS OUT.
WE HAVE ONE MORE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
RETURNS